Hi, I’m Adriene Hill, and welcome back to
Crash Course Statistics.
And sadly, we’re nearing the end of this
course.
We’ve covered a LOT of topics.
From probability, to t-tests, to Machine Learning
to Bayesian statistics.
Today, we’re going to go more “Real World.”
We’re going to talk about how statistics
is used in the courtroom to make...pretty
important...decisions.
In particular, we’re going to look at 3
individuals whose lives changed by the use
of statistics: Alfred Dreyfus, Sally Clark,
and Jonathan Dorfman.
INTRO
In 1894, a political scandal began in France
that would last until 1906 when Alfred Dreyfus--a
Jewish Officer in the French army--was convicted
of treason.
His conviction hinged on an unsigned letter--referred
to as the bordereau.
The letter offered French military secrets
for sale, and the courts decided that it was
Dreyfus who had written it.
Dreyfus was convicted, and for a time, sent
to live in a prison cell at Devil’s Island.
Which is about as pleasant as the name suggests.
This story is complicated.
Many books have been written about it.
But we’ll focus in particular on a handwriting
analysis done by Alphonse Bertillon--the founder
of the first crime laboratory for police in
France.
Bertillon alleged that Dreyfus purposely made
the bordereau look like a forgery of his own
handwriting.
That way, if he ever got caught, he could
claim someone had tried to frame him.
Bertillon theorized that Dreyfus created the
bordereau by tracing words and letters from
various sources, including one in his own
handwriting and his families’ handwriting.
That would make the document look more like
an forgery than something he’d actually
written.
One of the words Bertillon believed got traced
over and over was “intérêt” in Dreyfus’s
brother’s handwriting.
He’d found a letter written by the brother
and thought that the word in that letter looked
similar to some words in the bordereau.
The book Math on Trial: How Numbers Get Used
and Abused in the Courtroom breaks down his
process from here.
“Intérêt” contains five of the most
commonly used letters in the French language
-- e, n, r, i, and t.
So it would have been a logical one to pick
for repeated tracing.
Bertillon created a key to test his theory.
He traced “intérêt” in the brother’s
handwriting over and over with no spaces on
a line.
This is how he imagined Dreyfus would have
created a key of his own:
Conveniently, the bordereau was slightly transparent,
so Bertillon could place his key underneath
it, then look for places where letters overlapped.
And yes, there was some overlap, but the majority
of letters didn’t.
Then, he moved his key over a bit and saw
some new overlaps.
(And again, a lot of non-overlap).
But, he got excited by the overlapping letters
that he HAD seen, so he decided to make two
keys and put them both underneath the bordereau
with a little distance between them.
Then he counted up how many times the letters
e,n,r, and t overlapped.
And Bertillon concluded that the letters lined
up MUCH more than should be expected by chance.
Which...makes some sense.
I mean he had two keys.
Bertillon used the frequencies of these letters
in the bordereau to come up with the expected
frequencies of the overlaps.
So, the bordereau contained about 800 letters
and there were about 60 r’s.
If his key was just a bunch of R's, then every
r in the bordereau would line up with an r
on the key.
But since only 1 out of 7 letters in the key
were r’s, he expected 1 out of every 7 R's
in the bordereau to overlap with the key by
chance.
So, he expected the letter r to line up 9
times.
But it actually lined up 20 times.
All the other letters--with the exception
of ê--matched up more times than he expected.
But this logic was suspect.
A group of famous French mathematicians was
asked to inspect Bertillon’s “analysis.”
It didn’t hold up.
They went as far as to call it “completely
unfortunate”...which is about as mean as
French mathematicians got back then.
The expected probabilities that Bertillon
found may have been relatively accurate--but
only when he overlapped the key and the bordereau
ONE time.
Bertillon had overlapped them TWICE.
Which means he counted the overlapping letters
BOTH in the regular position (red) AND the
offset position (green).
And it was the rebuttal by Three French mathematicians
helped finally free Dreyfus.
Our next story starts in England in 1996 when
Sally Clark’s firstborn son Christopher
had the sniffles.
Doctors told Sally that it was a cold.
But later that month, she found Christopher
in distress and called an ambulance.
He later died.
In 1998, Sally’s second son, Harry, died
in a similar way.
A doctor’s examination of Harry found things
that could be indicative of abuse, such as
retinal hemorrhaging.
So, an investigation was conducted.
Steve and Sally Clark were arrested for murdering
their sons, but Steve was exonerated.
During the trial, Dr. Roy Meadow, a well respected
pediatrician, said the probability that one
of Sally’s children would die from Sudden
Infant Death Syndrome, or SIDS, was 1 in 8,543.
He then made an incredibly consequential probability
mistake by declaring that the probability
of TWO of these deaths happening in the same
family was 1 in 73 million.
Sally’s lawyer confronted Dr. Meadow on
whether the probability of Harry’s death
was still 1 in 8,543, even though his brother
had earlier died with the same diagnosis.
Essentially, he was asking whether these two
events were independent or if having one SIDS
related death in a family increases the probability
of having another.
And he was right to ask.
SIDS-related deaths in a family may not be
independent of each other.
We don’t know the cause of SIDS, but if
it’s even in part genetic or environmental,
it could be possible for babies in the same
family to have similar risks.
If Meadow had done the calculation with this
in mind, he would have most likely come to
a number MUCH lower than 1 in 73 million.
But that is not the only statistics error
that affected the Clark trial.
Whether the lawyers suggested it or the jury
assumed it, the unspoken assumption was that
there was only one other option: Murder.
And that since SIDS was so unlikely, murder
MUST be more likely.
The jury sentenced Clark to life in prison
for murdering her sons.
But there was another possibility...the deaths
could have been caused by naturally occurring
disease or circumstances.
That was found to be the case in Harry’s
death.
In 2003, Clark’s conviction was overturned
by a Court of Appeal because Harry’s medical
records indicated that he could have been
suffering from a Staph infection, which wasn’t
disclosed by a pathologist during the original
trial.
When we do statistics, we often only consider
one, or possibly two different hypotheses.
But it’s important to remember that there
are other OPTIONS out there.
When possible, we should try to consider those
other options.
Otherwise, we can accidentally commit this
Prosecutor’s fallacy, which incorrectly
claims that since the evidence found is SO
unusual or unlikely, that the jury could assume
that the accused defendant isn’t innocent.
And secondly, the fact that one hypothesis
is unlikely does not mean that another must
be more likely.
Fast forward to 2011, a student at the University
of California, San Diego, Jonathan Dorfman,
was accused of cheating on a midterm by his
Chemistry professor.
After two Academic Integrity Review Board
hearings, Dorfman was expelled from UCSD,
because he had a previous incident on his
record.
He then filed a lawsuit against the school.
After the midterm, the professor had noticed
that Dorfman had changed the Test Version
on his answer sheet.
There were four versions of the test -- A,
B, C, and D. Students were told that if their
test version wasn’t the same as the letter
on their answer sheet, they should tell their
test proctor.
Dorfman HAD changed the letter on his answer
sheet from D
to A. But, he said that he arrived late, so
he didn’t hear those instructions.
He just saw that his test booklet had a different
version than his answer sheet, and changed
the answer sheet to match the test.
After looking at all the exams, the professor
also noticed that Dorfman’s test matched
another student--they called them Student
X--who had test version A, the same one Dorfman
claimed to have.
24 of the 26 answers matched between the two
exams.
8 of the 10 incorrectly answered questions,
and all 16 of the correct ones.
The professor of the class took this as further
proof that Dorfman was cheating, and even
went as far as to get a statistician to say
that the probability of those same eight wrong
answers happening by chance was a billion
to one.
Though the court documents do not reveal the
exact math that the statistician used, it
seems possible that they, like Dr. Meadow
in Sally Clark’s case, probably assumed
independence when no such assumption should
be made.
The wrong answers that students choose aren’t
always totally random.
On multiple choice tests, many times there’s
one answer that looks good, even if it’s
slightly inaccurate.
And since these students were all taking the
same course, and reading the same textbook,
their incorrect answers aren’t independent
of each other.
Their misconceptions of the material were
VERY likely to be dependent on their learning
environment and therefore related.
Dorfman’s lawyer displayed this, during
the second review board hearing, by showing
44 of the 618 students who took this test
(in all its versions) had 23-25 answers matching
Dorfman’s.
So this one in a billion stat that was presented
to the court can be misleading.
To most people, the stat seems believable
at first glance.
And much of the University’s initial argument
relied on it.
So much so, that they refused to identify
Student X--off of whom Dorfman allegedly cheated.
The evidence, they claimed, was so strong
that further information about Student X wasn’t
required for the case to move forward.
The court determined that by not identifying
Student X, the university had given Dorfman
an unfair disadvantage in his hearings.
By not showing who Student X was there was
no way to prove that they weren’t cooperating
or that they weren’t sitting next to each
other.
More information about Student X would allow
us to update our 1 in a billion chance with
new information, much like we update beliefs
in Bayesian Statistics.
Taken alone, the probabilities can be misleading.
The Court ruled in favor of Dorman, saying
that if UCSD ever wanted to bring more charges
against him, that they’d need to find Student
X.
Many cases are influenced by poor probability
calculations.
Understanding basic rules about probability
and statistics, and being skeptical of the
probabilities you may hear can have a huge
impact on whether or not you come to the right
conclusions.
Thanks for watching, I’ll see you next time.